شكرا للزميل محمد الطميحي مشاهدينا
تتواصلوا تغطيه العربيه للوضع في السودان
حيث ندخل اليوم السابع من المواجهات
واليوم الاول من اول ايام عيد الفطر عدد
القتلى حسب مصادر رسميه اصبح اكثر من 600
شخص وهو مرشح للزياده نقابه الاطباء
السودانيه اكدت للعربيه مقتل احد عشر
طبيبا على الاقل منذ بدء الاشتباكات وانها
تعمل على فتح مستشفيات ميدانيه كحل مؤقت
الجيش السوداني بدوره اكد للعربيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع خرقت الهدنه باستهداف مناطقك
متفرقه في الخرطوم بالاضافه الى حشد قواته
في المناطق الحيويه المتحدث باسم الجيش
اكد للعربيه ايضا انه تم التصدي للدعم
السريع بمحيط القياده العامه ومطار
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه افاد كذلك بان
الجيش السوداني يسير دوريات مشاه بعده
شوارع في العاصمه الخرطوم وفي كلماته
للسودانيين بمناسبه عيد الفطر قال رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
ان الجيش لا يزال ملتزما بالانتقال الى
الحكم المدني واكد البرهان في اول خطاب
اعلني له منذ بدايه الازمه ان السودان
سيخرج من هذه المحنه اقوى من ذي قبل
الخراب والدمار واصوات الرصاص ما تركت
مجالا لفرحين يستحقه اهلنا في كل الربوع
بلادنا الحبيبه فاننا لجد حزينون لهذا
المال لكن يبقى الامل الدائم في اننا مع
شعبنا العظيم سنتجاوز هذه المحنه ونخرج
منها اكثر وحده وقوه وتماسك ويزداد هتافنا
قوه جيش واحد شعب واحد فاننا على ثقه في
تجاوز هذه المحنه بالدربه والحكمه والقوه
بما يحافظ على امن وحده البلاد وفيما
يمكننا من الانتقال الامن للحكم المدني
المواطنين الشرفاء انما اذ نترحم على كل
الشهداء بلادي نتمنى الشفاء للجرحى وندعو
الله ان يعود علينا هذا العيد وبلادنا
تنعم بالامن والسلام
تحيه لكم جند بلادي وانتم تقدمون انفسكم
فداء لهذا الوطن العزيز عاش السودان حره
مستقلا
[موسيقى]
مصادر في الجيش السوداني اكدت ان الحديث
عن هدنه لم يعد مطروحا الان امام قوه
الدعم السريع وان عمليات التمشيط وتامين
المناطق السكنيه في العاصمه الخرطوم تجري
بسلاسه كما اشارت مصادر الجيش الى ان قوات
الدعم السريع انهارت ولم يتبقى الا جيوب
قليله بالاضافه الى ان مواقع الدعم السريع
في العاصمه الخرطوم اصبحت معدوده بحسب
المصادر
معناتها بقى هنا بالغاز
هذا هو نشرت قوته الدعم السريع بيانا
نتامت فيه قوات الجيش بمواصله اطلاق النار
بعد مرور ساعه على دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ كما اكدت في البيان انها لن تقف
مكتوفه الايدي امام خرق الجيش الهدنه
وانها ستقوم بالدفاع عن نفسها هذا وكانت
قوات الدعم السريع اعلنت في وقت سابق عن
هدنه انسانيه احاديه الجانب لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه اعتبارا من صباح اليوم الجمعه
قال فارس النور مستشار قائد قوه الدعم
السريع في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه ان هدفهم
هو التحول الديمقراطي حتى وان كلف الامر
استمرار المعارك
الذي غلب الطاوله ان
الذين يريدون ان يعودوا بنا الى النظام
السابق حسوا ان القوه في السودان
صادمه في الوصول الى اتفاق ينتمي بها الى
الديمقراطيه فحسوا بالخطر فكانوا لابد
كانت لابد ان يتحركوا حتى ان يح
افظ يفشل الامر وانا هنا اقول اننا
ندعو جميع القوى المدنيه جميعها سواء
الذين في الاطار وغير الاطار
[موسيقى]
الى
الاتحاد وتكوين اكبر جبهه ميدانيه لمواجهه
هذا الخطر
لمخاطبه المجتمع الدولي بضروره الانتقال
الى التحول الديمقراطي
استخدم الجيش السوداني صواريخ موجهه عاليه
الدقه لاول مره منذ بدء المواجهه مع قوات
الدعم السريع نشاهد
انتشر مقطع يظهر سيارات دفع رباعي مدمره
تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع تعرضت لقصف من
القوات الجويه السودانيه بطائره ميج 29
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضم الينا الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
صلاح خليل سيد صلاح كل عام وانت بخير
مرحبا بك معي في هذه
النشره او في هذه الساعه والتغطيه للمشهد
والاحداث في السودان الجيش السوداني في
تصريحات للعربيه قبل قليل يقول بانه تجاوز
مرحله الصمود وبدا مرحله تنظيف بؤر انتشار
الدعم السريع ما الذي يقصده بهذا الحديث
برايك وفي اي مرحله نحن من هذا المشهد
السوداني الجديد والمتازم
نعم ما قاله الجيش السوداني هو في دلاله
واشاره واضحه بان قوات الدعم السريعه
ربما يعني تم القضاء عليها وهنالك جيوب
مقاومه ربما داخل الاحياء
وتستخدم بعض المناطق وبعض السودانيين في
الاهياء كدروب بشريه وهي ايضا فيها اشاره
واضحه
لقوات الدعم السريعه التي تقاتل
من اجل
من اجل ان تدافع عن الشخصيات ليس لديها
علاقه الدوله السودانيه وبمانا صح تحارب
باقي المؤسسه عسكريه تنتمي اليها الدوله
السودانيه تنتمي لها الشعب السوداني
فبالتالي ليس ما قاله الجيش وهي في اشاره
واضحه بان
المعاركين انتهت وانتقلت الى المرحله
الاخيره وهي التي راينا اليوم
العديد من التيارات الدفع الرباعي التي
كانت داخل الخرطوم تتجه
من خارج الخرطوم عبر شارع مدني للخروج من
الخرطوم وهي
ربما تجد كمان ايضا هنالك مضادات من الجيش
من قوات الدفاع الدفاع الجوي السوداني
وايضا من الطائرات المسيره فبالتالي ربما
هي الماركه انتهت فيتقاد الشخصي
وكثير لكن يعني قبل قليل يعني اذا كنت
تشاهد الاخبار العاجله اسفل
الشاشه سيد صلاح مجموعه
اللازمات الدوليه تتحدث بان الاشتباكات
بالسودان قد تتطور لحرب اهليه اذا لم
تتوقف الان
فورا ما الذي يعني هذا الامر دلاله ايضا
هذه التصريحات وانت تقول بان المعركه قد
حسمت فعليا على الارض
تتحول الى حرب اهليه اذا كانت تمكنت قوات
الدعم السريع من الخروج من الخرطوم
وبالتالي اتجهت الى مناطق النشاه والتكوين
او مناطق جزولها سواء كانت في مناطق
دارفور في الخمسه ولكن
انتقال الى حرب اهليه لا اعتقد لان هي لم
تتمكن من او من اوددها الى مناطقها من
الضربات الاولى اذا كانت تمكنت قوات الدعم
السليمه لالتهاب التكتيك السريع ورجعت الى
مناطق النشاه والتكوين ربما قد يكون هنالك
حرب اهليه ربما تكون هنالك حرب قبليه في
مناطق في ولايات التي تتمركز فيها خاصه
ولكن
الاشاره هنا الواطيها عدم القبره لقوات
الدعم السريع وعدموا وجود تكتيك او
استراتيجيه او رؤيا لانها تخوض حرب امام
مؤسسه عسكريه كبيره او مؤسسه عسكريه في
السودان لديها تاريخ وبالتالي دفعهم
يتمركزونه داخل الخرطوم
متى انقضى القضاء عليهم داخل الخرطوم لا
اعتقد ان هنالك
حدوث لقوات الدعم السريع وايضا تعتبر
نهايه لكابوز يلا السودانيين يعانون منه
منذ
الحكومه البشير اسست هذه القوه وجعلتها
فهو موازنه او كقوه تمتاز
طيب سيد صلاح يعني هو السؤال لماذا تتركز
الان كل هذه المواجهات العسكريه كل
التشكيلات العسكريه سواء للدعم السريع او
للجيش السوداني داخل العاصمه الخرطوم نعلم
ان السودان تملك مساحه شاسعه وكبيره جدا
لها حدود مع سبع دول لماذا تتركز
الاشتباكات فقط في العاصمه
سؤال جيد سؤال جيد جدا التمركز في العاصمه
اليه دلالات ارتكبتها لجنه التمكين في
الفتره الماضيه عندما قامت بهل جهاز هيئه
العمليات التابعه لجهاز المخابرات وسلمت
مقاله لقوات الدعم السريع وايضا عندما
سلمت حزب المؤتمر الوطني المنحل اللي هو
الاقرب الى مطار الخرطوم الى قياده الدعم
السريع قياده الدعم السريع كقوه
الجراحه انشاتها حكومه المؤتمر الوطني
كانت فيها فكره انها كقوه تقوم بالقضاء
على اي نوع من الاحتجاجات او الاشتباكات
التي تحصل داخل الخرطوم لذلك راينا
التمركز بتاعها داخل الخرطوم والطرقاتها
منذ 2013 احتجاج 2013 كانت قوات الدم
الطرقات والمظاهرات التي كانت من اجل
التعرف الى ملامح الخرطوم وشوارعها وطرقها
لا تتمكن مستقبلا عن تجابه وانتماطح
المؤسسه العسكريه
الدافع ذلك هي الميزانيه الكبيره التي
قصصتها لها الحكومه السابقه حكومه البشير
فجعلتها انها تكون
كميليشيات واحده انها ترى نفسها انها هي
اقوى من الجيش السوداني وهذا هو خطا كبير
جدا يدل بوضوح ان الدعم السريع ليس لديه
استراتيجيه ليس لديه رؤيه حتى في في
طريقته في كسب الرايه السوداني ساعود معك
الى الحديث عن عن المقارنه بين
استراتيجيتي الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لكن
ابقى معي سيد
صلاح ساعود اليك مره اخرى اذا في الملف
الانساني مشاهدينا قالت منظمه اطباء بلا
حدود الدوليه ان فريقها الطبي لا يمكنه
ادخال اي امدادات طبيه اضافيه الى السودان
في ظل الاشتباكات الحاليه محذره بانه ان
لم يتغير الوضع في المنطقه سيكون هناك
المزيد من الخسائر في الارواح كما اشارت
المنظمه في بيان الى ان الامدادات التي
تقدمها في مستشفى الفاشر ساب تكفيف فقط
لثلاثه اسابيع اضافيه في حال عدم ادخال اي
امدادات جديده الى المستشفى
هذا وقال مسؤولون في القطاع الصحي ان
المستشفى الدولي هو الوحيد الذي يعمل في
منطقه بحري خلال فجر العيد واستقبل سبع
اصابات نتيجه المعارك الدائره بين الجيش
والدعم السريع كلهم من المدنيين العاملون
يشتكون من قله الكوادر الطبيه وشح
الامدادات بالاضافه الى ترويع قوات الدعم
السريع للكوادر التي تعمل داخل المستشفى
ضربات
الحرب فوق
ال 130 عصابه
[موسيقى]
المدنيين
يتعدد 80%
بالنسبه
البحري بمعانا
لازم الطبيه ومن هنا بنائيه
المفروض كل
عينيها محتاجين لايك قاعده حتى لو زعفات
اوليه بيقدر يشتغل
معي هنا في الاستوديو مديريه مكتب العربيه
في الخرطوم
اهلا وسهلا بك معي في هذه التغطيه كل عام
وانت بخير عيدكم مبارك اولا
ظروف صعبه للسودان لينا اريد معك ان نتحدث
عن الجانب الصحي عن الكوادر ايضا الطبيه
في السودان وضع المستشفيات بشكل عام كيف
يمكن تقييمه حسب المعلومات التي تملكينها
اهلا بك نايف مجددا الوضع الصحي في
السودان سيء بحسب العاملين في القطاع
الصحي في المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه هناك
نقص لمستلزمات طبيه ضروريه وهناك ازدحام
في بعض المستشفيات واغلاق لمستشفيات
ومراكز صحيه اخرى هناك قلق من العاملين في
هذا المجال نسبه لوجود عدد من المستشفيات
الحكوميه في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك في
مناطق تشهد اشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تم اخلاء هذه المقر اما بطلب مباشر
من الجهات التي تقوم بهذا الاشتباك ان
كانت بقرب المستشفيات او بقرار من مدراء
المستشفى لضمان امن وسلامه المرضى وكذلك
سلامه العاملين لذلك هناك كثير من
المستشفيات التي رايناها امس في الخرطوم
كانت مغلقه تماما وخارج الخدمه ايضا
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء وعدم وجود انابيب
الاكسجين وعدم وجود مستلزمات طبيه ضروريه
تعطل بعض الاجهزه ادى بصوره مباشره الى ان
لا تكون هذه المستشفيات ذات فاعليه لذلك
كان هناك قرار باخلاء هذه المستشفيات
الوضع الصحي السيء هناك اعتماد على
الصيدليات اعتماد على بعض المتطوعين في
هذا المجال هناك اتصالات وارقام الان
موضوعه على بعض صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
حتى يتمكن المرضى من الاتصال بمن هم اقرب
اليهم في هذه المنطقه حتى يتمكنوا اصلا
بالاساس هذه المستشفيات ايضا او حتى
الكوادر الطبيه اللي موجوده في العاصمه
الخرطوم تحديدا هل كانت تعمل بكفاءه عاليه
اصلا قبل بدايه هذا الصراع وهذه الازمه
ام عكس ذلك يعني الامور كانت سيئه اصلا
حتى قبل هذا النزاع بين الطرفين طبعا هي
لم تكن ذات فاعليه قصوى ولكنها كانت تعمل
وكانت تؤدي واجبات كبيره جدا هناك مرضى لا
يحتملون التاخير مثل مرضى السرطان الذين
يحتاجون غسيل كولا وغيرهم كانوا على الاقل
يتواجدون في هذه المستشفيات ويتلقون
العلاج صحيح ان بعض الجرعات تتاخر ولكن
على الاقل تكون موجوده صحيح ان هناك غرف
تكون فارغه حتى ياتي اليها المرضى ولكنهم
بعد معاناه يستطيعون الحصول عليها الان
هذا الامر غير متاح الوضع في الحرب ليس
مثل وضع التردي الاقتصادي الذي يؤدي الى
تردي الخدمات الرئيسيه مثل الصحه والتعليم
وغيرها لذلك الوضع كان لا باس به مقارنه
طبعا
بما هو الان
نعم
تحدثتي قبل قليل عن نقطه مهمه وهي المرضى
الموجودين في في هذه المستشفيات الذين
يستلزم وجودهم في ربما العنايه المركزه
امراض السرطان ايضا او حتى
الغسيل الكلوي هل تضرروا من هذه الازمه
باي شكل ايضا كان هناك من معلومات من
اخبار ايضا تبعتها ولصقتها خلال الايام
الماضيه
هناك شهود عيان هناك مناشدات يعني تاتي
ني على اتصالات من بعض المتواجدين داخل
المستشفى
ليحكوا عبر القناه ما تمر به هذه المستشفى
والحالات التي يتعرضون اليها هناك محاولات
لنقل هؤلاء المرضى الى خارج الخرطوم بعض
الولايات السودانيه اامن من العاصمه لذلك
الان يتم نقل المرضى وهو نزوح جديد نزوح
للمرضى من مستشفيات الخرطوم الى العاصمه
من مستشفيات الخرطوم الى الولايات ورغم
انه كان في السابق ياتون مرضى الولايات
الى العاصمه الان هذا هو الامر الذي يتم
هناك انعكست بالضبط نايف وهناك الان
محاولات يعني تتم لبعض المراكز الصحيه
ذات امكانيات محدوده بان يتم مدها ببعض
الاسره بعض المستلزمات الطبيه اجهزه الان
هناك قرار بان تتعاون هذه المستشفيات مع
بعضها البعض المستشفيات المغلقه ان تقوم
بنقل بعض الاجهزه الى مراكز صحيه ليست ذات
امكانيات كبيره حتى بعض المهام اجواء
العيد كما ذكرنا في السودان هذا العيد
مختلفه تماما ربما لاول مره ممكن في في
تاريخ السودان يمر بهكذا مشهد او بهكذا
شكل حسب كل الضيوف واللي على الاقل اليوم
تحدثوا معنا من خلال مرضتي عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي التواصل مع الاهل كيف
كانت اجواء العيد اليوم في الخرطوم تحديد
في انايف وربما رمضان يشهد اصبح يعني يعني
مرتين في مره في عهد البشير في عام 89
بعدها تولي السلطه طبعا يعني كان هناك
ايضا اعدام ل 28 ضابط ايضا في رمضان هذا
الامر اثر بصوره كبيره على السودانيين قبل
نحو ثلاثه اعوام كان اعتصام القياده
العامه كان ايضا في في اواخر رمضان ايضا
اثر على السودانيين لذلك الان الاحساس لدى
السودانيين ان دائما اصبح عيد الفطر مرتبط
لديهم بعمل عسكري معين يؤثر بصوره مباشره
على شكل حياتهم الان رغم الهدنه التي
اعلنت امس رغم احساس التفاؤل الذي انتبههم
بان على الاقل اول يوم العيد بامكانهم
المعايده بامكانهم الذهاب الى مناطق
مختلفه لزياره الاقارب والاهل هذا الامر
لم يتم لان الانتشار العسكري في الشوارع
ما زال موجود وهذا الانتشار للجيش ولا
الدعم سنعود للحديث عن
عيد الخرطوم هذا العام لكن اجواء العيد
مشاهدينا في السودان وفي ظل هذه
الاشتباكات اجواب حزينه بالتاكيد حيث
استقبل السودانيون المناسبه باصوات الرصاص
وهي ترافق تكبيرات الصلاه نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا وادى سكان مدينه ام درمان في العاصمه
الخرطوم صلاه العيد وطلب المصلون بوقف
المعارك واحلال السلام في بلادهم مع حلول
عيد الفطر وبدء هدنه جديده مدتها 72 ساعه
من جانب واحد
[موسيقى]
بصراحه فيه
يا رب انعم علينا بالسلام والبركه والخير
يعني وتتوقف الحرب والناس توصلوا يعني
للاتفاق بتاع سلام والناس تعيش امني
وسلامه نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان نرجع
السودان الاصلي
بالامن والاستقرار وربنا يحقق الاماني ان
شاء الله والبلد تكون فيه استقرار ان شاء
الله الوضع يتحسن ان شاء الله ربنا يجنم
ظهر منها البطن والحق ما فيها طرف ناجح كل
الطرفين الخاسرين لانه كنا سودانيين ربنا
يصلح
الحال وعشيه العيد اظهرت صورهم خاصه
بالعربيه زحاما للمواطنين امام محطه وقود
في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
يعود مره اخرى الى مديره مكتب العربيه في
الخرطوم يعقوب يعني من خلال هذه الصور
هناك تكدس كبيره امام محطات الوقود في
العاصمه
الخرطوم بالاضافه ايضا الى بعض الاخبار
المتداوله تتحدث عن نفاذ بعض المواد
الغذائيه ايضا حتى في العاصمه الخرطوم
ماذا لديك من معلومات حول هذا الامر يعني
انت الان راينا سويا هذا التكدس في بعض
محطات الوقود هناك تدمير لمحطات وقود اخرى
في نعم هناك محطات وقود مدمره لا تعمل
وهناك محطات وقود نفذت نفذ منها الوقود
وامداد البترول لذلك هي الان مغلقه وهناك
تكدس في المحطات التي تعمل اصبحت الحركه
الاشهيحه خاصه للمواصلات العامه البساطه
السفريه وغيرها كان هناك شحوره راينا ايضا
تكدس للمسافرين في بعض الاماكن التي تنقل
المسافرين مثل السوق الشعبي البري وهي
اماكن داخليا بين الولايات السودانيه من
الخرطوم الى الولايات الاخرى هناك تكدس
لان الوقود منعدم وهناك طبعا قلق ايضا من
اصحاب الباصات بالنسبه للسفر الداخلي من
الخرطوم الى ولايات اخرى ولكن السبب
الاساسي الان هو نقص الوقود لان الامداد
الان من الشركات البترول لهذه المحطات لا
يتم نسبه لانتشار كما ذكرت الدبابات وبعض
العربات التي تتبع للدعم السريع او للجيش
في الشوارع وهناك قلق من هذا الامر ممتاز
بالنسبه للسلع الغذائيه هناك نفاذ لكثير
من السلع الغذائيه خاصه النواشف مثل
يعني المكرونه البسكويت بعض الاشياء نفذت
لكن هناك توفر للخضروات
فالسودانيين الان لا ياخذون كل هذه
الخضروات الى المنزل بالنسبه لانقطاع
الكهرباء وكذلك اللحوم
لن تصلح هذه المواد للبقاء في المنزل في ظ
انقطاع الكهربائي لفتره طويله ولكن هناك
نفاذ بالسلع كبيره الان وكثيره موجوده في
هذه الاسواق هل الامر مقتصر فقط على
العاصمه الخرطوم ام كل الولايات السودانيه
وكل المدن العاصمه الخرطوم هي الاكثر ضررا
وهي الاكثر تضررا في موضوع السلع موضوع
الامداد المائي والكهربائي وكذلك في موضوع
الوقود هناك ولايات سودانيه تشهد استقرار
النسبيه في كل هذه الامور هناك ولايات مثل
دارفور تشهد ايضا تضررا في الجانب الصحي
بصوره كبيره والجانب ايضا الانساني نسبه
لوجود اشتباكات هناك ولكن بقيه المناطق
هادئه نسبيا ربما اليوم المتابع للشان
السوداني يسال انه لماذا تتركز هذه
الاشتباكات فقط في الخرطوم هل هي فقط في
الخرطوم ام موجوده في ولايات او مدن اخرى
ايضا سودانيه لكن اقل حده والاشتباكات
اقل او اخف وبالتالي التركيز دائما على
العاصمه الخرطوم
هذه حاله استثنائيه الدعم السريع نايف في
الاشهر الماضيه دعنا نتحدث او السنوات
الماضيه كان ينقل عدد من القوات من
الولايات السودانيه تحديدا من دارفور الى
العاصمه الخرطوم كانت كان هذا النقل يتم
عبر مراحل متباعده ومتقطعه ولاسباب مختلفه
لكنهم جاءوا ومكثوا في معسكرات كانت تتبع
سابقا لهيئه العمليات لجهاز المخابرات بعد
ذلك اصبح يمكث فيها الدعم لا جهاز
المخابرات العامه نعم الذي تم حله لم يحل
هو كمؤسسه ولكن تم حل هيئه العمليات داخل
جهاز المخابرات هيئه العمليات كانت تضم
قوات كثيره وفي مراكز مختلفه بعد ذلك جاء
الدعم السريع ومكث في هذه الاماكن لذلك
هناك تكدس لهذه القوات داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم في عهد البشير لم يكون الامر كذلك
كانت وجودها في دارفور اكبر واكثر من
العاصمه لكن الان اصبح الوضع مختلف هذا هو
الذي يسبح وجود قوات الدعم السريع اكثر في
العاصمه الخرطوم نعم وبالتالي وجودها في
دارفور هل انتهى تماما ام بقيت لها جيوب
وتشكيلات لا لا لم ينتهي هي الان تتواجد
بقوه في ولايات دارفور وكذلك تتواجد بقوه
في العاصمه الخرطوم ليس لديها وجود يذكر
مثلا في ولايات مثل نهر النيل سنار كسلا
هناك ولايات سودانيه في
مروه حاولت الدخول لمرويه هذه المره لم
يكن لها وجود من قبل فحينما جاءت لتدخل
لولايه جديده غير الولايات التي تتواجد
فيها حدثت شراره الحرب من مروي حينما جاء
الدبابات للقاعده الجويه السودانيه ثم بعد
ذلك اشتعلت شراره الحرب بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
المعلومات كل هذه التفاصيل التي
تناولناها هنا مع ضيفه في الاستوديو مديره
مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
لينا اذا مشاهدينا كما اسلفنا ومع اول
ايام العيد شهدت بعض شوارع الخرطوم بحري
انتشارا امنيا مكثفا لقوات الجيش مع اول
ايام عيد الفطر مراسل العربيه افاد بدوره
بان الجيش السوداني بدا بتسيير دوريات
مشات
بعده شوارع في الخرطوم نتابع
معناتها بقى هنا بالشارع كلها
كما اظهرت مقاطع فيديو متداوله انتشار
الجيش السوداني في شوارع اخرى من العاصمه
الخرطوم وسط ترحيب الاهالي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا المحلل العسكري
الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين مرحبا بك معي
سعاده الفريق في هذه التغطيه كل عام وانت
بخير عيد مبارك اريد ان اسال عن الخارطه
العسكريه اليوم تحديدا في الخرطوم كيف
يمكن الحديث عنها كيف تقراها ايضا
وكل عام وانتم بخير
واقول ان الخارطه العسكريه اليوم يعني
القوات المسلحه انتقلت الى مرحله اخرى من
مراحل الدفاع الى مراحل تمشيط طرقات
الخرطوم لتطهيرها من عناصر الدعم السريع
يجب ان نشير هنا الى النقطه الضروريه جدا
عناصر الدعم السريع خلال الثلاثه ايام
الماضيه اقامه نقاط ارتكاز في معظم شوارع
الخرطوم الداخليه
والقوميه هذه النقاط يعني ما بين كل نقطه
والاخرى مسافه لا تزيد عن واحد كيلو متر
يعني لا يمكن ان تتحرك مسافه الا وارتفع
في ايه نقطه ارتكاز نقطه الارتكاز هذه تف
[موسيقى]
اتحدث باي شكل تضرر المدنيين هل استهدف
منهم اي احد بهذه الطريقه
الاف وليست عشرات وليست مئات
لتنظيف هذه الارزات ولا زالت هنالك
ارتكازات في مناطق اخرى ايضا سيذهب اليها
في مرحله قادمه لكن الان جنوب الخرطوم
يعني حتى منطقه الباقير انا اعتقد انها
اصبحت نظيفه تماما من هذه الافتكازات ايضا
بحري مساحه واسعه في بحر تم تطهير تماما
من هذه الارتكازات وشاهدتم في في
الماضي هذا كيف ان الاهالي يرحبون بلغات
المسلحه وفرحون جدا بوجود القوات المسلحه
في طرقاتهم لان الدعم السريع ازالهم
الامرين في اليومين الامس عانوا معانوا من
من عناصر الدعم السريع
هذه العناصر للاسف في اليومين الماضيين
كسروا كثير من المحلات التجاريه ونهبوها
كسروا بنك العمال نهبوا بنك السودان يعني
احاسوا فسادا وخرابا لا يتصور فكان لابد
للغات المسلحه ان تنتشر في الشوارع لكي
تطهر الشوارع من هذا الدنس وانا اعتقد
انها الان قطعتا جيدا في ذلك الشيء الاخر
والضروري نشير اليه هنا استثناء نايف
من
[موسيقى]
جدا الان يعني الكهرباء تكون رجعت الى
وضعها الطبيعي
يوم السبت الماضي يعني يوم السبت الماضي
اصلا كنا نعيش في برمجه الصباحيه ومسائيه
الان تقريبا رجعنا الى نفس البرنامج اهو
افضل منه غنيلا ايضا عن انقطاعات يعني في
في بعض الاحياء في العاصمه الخرطوم ولا
نتحدث عن كامل العاصمه يعني
موجود يعني قبل يوم السبت الماضي قبل هذا
التمرد كان الكهرباء فيها نقش في التوليد
تقطع في الصباح احيانا وتقطع مساء احيانا
بشكل كامل دون انقطاع
نعم عادت بشكل كامل بدون انقطاع الان في
الخرطوم
يعني هذا شكلها طبيعي تقصد يعني
مقطع مناطق بالصباح
وهذا برنامج السودانيين كلهم متعارفين
عليه فالكهرباء تقريبا عادت الى ما كانت
عليه قبل يوم السبت الماضي لكن بالتاكيد
[تصفيق]
يجب ان نشير الى نجاه مهمه جدا اولا
نقابه اطباء
الاطباء السودانيه هي نغابه مسيسه
غير صحيح ومنافق الواقع
المنظمه الصحه العالميه مناديب الموجودين
في السودان انا مستحيل ان اجزم ان
احد منهم خرج من شغلته لكي يعرف ماذا يحدث
خارج الشغله وهذا يحدث المؤسسات العلاجيه
وانا مستعد اجزم على ذلك
لماذا تتهمها بانها بان بانها مسيسه يعني
ما هي ماخذك عليهم وعلى تصريحاتهم يعني هم
تحدثوا بان هناك
بعض الارقام بعض التصريحات لهم وعلق عليها
اذا سمحت فقط
من الناطق الرسمي لوزاره الصحه هنالك
وزاره سياديه مسؤوله من الصحه في السودان
لها ناطق رسمي اسمه دكتور محمد ابراهيم
تحدثوا مع الدكتور محمد ابراهيم لكي يفتح
لكم عن
يتعلق بالقطاع تحدثنا تحدثنا مع الصحه
السودانيه نقلت لنا نقلت لنا ارقام
طريقه فتح الرحمن ولكن اعطيك فقط بيانات
بسيطه الخرطوم بها 135 مستشفى
مستش
فيات كاس من الخدمه بسبب وجوده
حول القياده العامه التي تدور في هذه
الاشتباكات هنالك 103 مستشفى الان عامله
في الخرطوم وليس هنالك يعني حقيقه يكون في
معاناه للمواطن لكي يصل الى المستشفى بسبب
ليس بسبب القتال وليس بسبب القوات المسلحه
وانما بسبب النقاط الارتكاز التي كانت
تفريدها عناصر الدعم السريع في هذا هو
الواقع يجب ان لا نزيف الحدائق يجب ان
نكون حقيقيين نوضح للناس حتى فقط يفهم حتى
فقط يفهم المشاهد ما اخذك فريق فتح الرحمن
انا اريد ان انقل لك فقط ما قالته نقابه
الاطباء السوداني وانت تعلق بعد ذلك هي
قالت بان هناك 14 مستشفى تعرضت لقصف
البلاد وذكرت بان 11 طبيبا قتلوا منذ بدء
الاشتباكات في البلاد قالت بانه يجب فتح
ممرات انسانيه بشكل فوري وقالت نعمل على
فتح مستشفيات ميدانيه كحل مؤقت هذا مجمل
ما قالته نقابه الاطباء السودانيه هذا
اليوم كيف تعلق عليها
اولا قالت هنالك اكثر من 400 شهيد
هنالك اكثر من 3,3600 جريح هذا غير صحيح
عدد الشهداء لم يصل هذا الرقم وعدد الجرح
لم يصل هذا
الارقام حتى الان ان كان لديك معلومات كم
وصلت اعداد الارقام
حتى الامس استمعنا الى الناطق الرسمي في
قناتكم او في على ما اظن قال لكم ان هنالك
107 شهيد حتى الامس 107 شهيد 80 شهيد منهم
ذويهم استلموا
وستروها
وزير الصحه وزير الصحه السوداني قال بان
هناك اكثر من 600 وفاه السودانيه
وقسما بالله هو نفس الو
صيه واتحداه ان كان حديث صحيحا الا اذا
كان يتحدث عن غفله
الدعم السوري حديث صحيحا لكن انا اتحدث عن
الغتله المدنيين اسفل الغفله العسكريين
سواء كان من القوات المسلحه او من الدفاع
او من الدعم السريع نحن
لا يعمل ومن يموت منهم
هذا واجبهم ولا هذه
ونتحدث
عنه يجب على نقابه ان تتحدث عن هؤلاء ويجب
على وزير الصحه ان يحدثكم
ولا طبعا جمله القتله الرحمن غير الناطق
الرسمي بالامس اليوم صحيح
كل الجثث التي وصلت المستشفى
وهذه هي الارقام الرسميه واخر الارقام
طبعا التي اعلن عنها وزير الصحه نشكرك
جزيل الشكر على كل حال من الخرطوم المحلل
العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين شكرا
جزيلا لك
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل عاده الحياه بشكل حذر
الى مدينه مروي شمال السودان بعد ان
تراجعت عده الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع كما شهدت القاعده العسكريه
في المدينه صلاه العيد لهذا اليوم
عندما نلاقيه بباب الريان اعمال الجميله
كل عام وانت بخير
نحن الان داخل الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشاه في
مدينه ملوي بالولايه الشماليه هذه ملامح
العيد في اول يوم من ايام عيد الفطر
المبارك
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ومن ارض مروعي طيب الصامته الطاهره
لنرسل الرساله
للشعب السوداني
ان شاء الله
واكد تماما بان الولايه خاليه تماما من اي
وجود للفلول عدد من الاسر في الولايات
الشماليه وتحديدا في مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه فقدت ابنائها خلال الاشتباكات
العنيفه المسلحه التي دارت خلال العمليات
العسكريه داخل المطار وداخل القاعده
العسكريه سنقترب اكثر لنتعرف على شكل
العيد في الاسر التي فقدت بعضا من ابنائها
خلال هذه الحرب
السلام ورحمه الله
ولدي
الشهيد احمد محمد احمد عوض الله
الذي استشهد بمطار مرعي والقاعده الجويه
هو عند الله شهيدا ان شاء الله
والحمد لله رب العالمين
في في الاحداث اللي فاتت دي
وعندنا والله
يعني لطالما ترسخت الطمانينه والامن في
هذه المنطقه كرسوق اشجار النخيل في ارض
الشمال ياتي العيد ودعوات الناس هنا ان
يعم الامن والاستقرار والسلام ارجى
السودان نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه
والحدث محليه مروي الولايه الشماليه
على الصعيد الدولي نقلت العربيه عن
دبلوماسيه اوروبي قوله ان العمل جار مع
الهيئات الدوليه ودول الخليج من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار وتثبيت الهدنه في السودان
واضاف الدبلوماسي الاوروبي ان السودان
دوله محوريه في افريقيا
وتاثيرات النزاع فيها قد تطال المنطقه من
غرب افريقيا الى القرن الافريقي
من جهتها قالت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
انها على تواصل مستمر مع سلطات السودانيه
لتسهيل عوده مواطنيها عبر المعابر البريه
في السودان دون عوائق اضافه الخارجيه في
بيان نشره على فيسبوك انها تواصل من خلال
بعثاتها في السودان بذل كافه الجهود
والقيام بالاتصالات اللازمه لمتابعه اوضاع
الجاليه المصريه في البلاد خلال الازمه
والتعاطي السريع معها تبعا للمستجدات
هذا وقال سلفاكير رئيس جنوب السودان ان
بلاده فوجئت بالاشتباكات العسكريه التي
شهدتها الخرطوم واكد سلفاكير انه جاهز
للذهاب الى الخرطوم اذا ما قدمت السلطات
السياسيه ضمانات بان مطار الخرطوم لا
تهدده اي مشاكل امنيه الحرب
بانه ما كنا عارفين انه حيكون في حرب
لانه ذاته دخلنا فيه نتكلم الطرفين
يعني يقبل وسلام وما بينطى
منتظرين الاشاره من الخرطوم يقول لنا يا
جماعه
ما في صوره تلقى في الخرطوم
واي طائره ممكن تنزل في المطار بتاع
الخرطومه جولي
انا
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو تيرش
كان قد ناشد اطراف النزاع في السودان وقف
اطلاق النار داعيا لهدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام
طوال فتره عيد الفطر
كاولويه فوريه اناشد اطراف النزاع وقف
اطلاق النار لمده ثلاثه ايام على الاقل
احتفالا بعيد الفطر للسماحل المدنيين
بالفرار من مناطق النزاع والبحث عن العلاج
الطبي والامدادات الضروريه الاخرى يجب ان
يتبع ذلك حوار يسمح بالانتقال الناجح
للبدء بتعيين حكومه مدنيه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال فورا انا ايضا قلق للغايه بشان
حاله العديد من الاشخاص العاملين في الامم
المتحده داخل منطقه النزاع
عود مره اخرى الى القاهره والى الباحه في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه صلاح خليل سيد صلاح مرحبا
بك معي مره اخرى منشدات دوليه وامميه قبل
قليل ربما تابعت هذا الفيديو وهذه
المناشده من انطوني غوتيري شلامين العام
للامم المتحده هل يمكن ان تلقى هذه
الدعوات صدن في الداخل السوداني لوقف
اطلاق النار ام ان الامور تحتاج الى حسم
العسكري قبل الوصول الى هذه النقطه نقطه
وقف الاقتتال
اعتقد انه الموضوع المبادرات لوقف القتال
خلاص قد عدى احنا كل اليوم اليوم السابع
فبالتالي المؤسسه العسكريه قطعت شوط كبير
فانه لا تفاوض مع الميليشيات القبليه
فبالتالي اي مبادره او حتى وساطه من دول
الجوار او ما شابه ذلك فيتمري لا تجد قبول
لانها هي الازمه ازمه سودانيه داخليه فيجب
ان تحلل في اطار داخلي في زيل ايضا
هنالك
قائد شعبيه كبيره من المؤسسه العسكريه
راينا القوه السياسيه التي هي تسببت جزء
كبير فهذه الازمه تراجعت فبالتالي تدعيم
المؤسسه العسكريه فبالتالي
اي تدخلات او اي مبادرات للهدنه فاتقاد
الشخص للمؤسسه المؤسسه العسكريه لا تقبل
بذلك عسكريه
رات ماذا ارتكبت ميليشيات الدعم السريع في
خلال ترويع المواطنين نحو الممتلكات
فبالتالي
الميليشيات رجعت للطرق بتاعتها البدائيه
اللي كانت تستخدمها في اقاليم دارفور
وايضا رجعت الى الانتماءات الاوليه الضيقه
لان هي ليس لديها خبره ليس لديها رؤيه في
كيفيه التعامل مع المدنيين ولكن
في هذه الازمه بالتالي كيف يمكن ان تكون
جزءا من اي حل سياسي جزءا من اي وقف
اقتتال او هدنه بين الطرفين
انا لم اقول انها هي هي تراجعت من موقفها
تراجعت بموقفها لتدعم المؤسسه العسكريه
راينا الحريه والتغيير
المركزي اعتبر الدعم السريع
هنالك ناشطين وليس نقبا سياسيه فالناشطه
السياسي لا يمكن ان يكون لديه المقدره
بالتنبؤ بالازمات ووضع حلول وانا وانا
واثق ان الحريه والتخيير بكل مكوناتها لو
وضعت امام هذا السيناريو ان تضع مشاكل
السودان وتضع حلول لها على المدى القريب
او المتوسط سوف تفتيل في ذلك لانها هي قوه
براجمتها كانت في المحاماه الاول تريد ان
تحقق مصالح ماليه مصالح اقتصاديه
لمكوناتها وايضا ان تنفس اجندات ليست لا
ذات صله بالدوله السودانيه وايضا ليس
ساتصل بتفكيك الاجندات لديها تفكيك
للمؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه فبالتالي ربما
كان مؤسسه عسكريه والمخابرات اكتشفوا هذه
المؤامره لكان انزلقه السودان في فوضى
وانزلق في حرب اهليه وربما كانت تكون جزء
كبير في تفكيك الدوله السودانيه واعادتها
واعاده الفوائد الاقليميه والدوليه
كناشطين او كفوائي المؤثره في الازمه
الداخليه وبالتالي السيد صلاح هل تستبعد
نجاح اي وساطه لانهاء القتال مهما كانت
قدراتها سواء كانت اقليميه او دوليه
تقع اي وساطه حتى لو من الاتحاد الاوروبي
او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انا
باعتقادي الشخصي ضم يعني انتهت لان الان
المؤسسه العسكريه حققت مكاسب كبيره جدا
ولا يمكن تتراجع او تتفاوض مع ميليشيات
انت عندما تتحدث انما هنالك يكون هنالك
حوار او تفاوض انت تتفاوت مع جهه لديها
ارتكازات لديها قوه سانداها لديها قوه
سياسيه او لديها
لديها مكونات فائله معها انت انت هنا
التفاوضات بالرغمي انه الفريق البرهان لم
يشير على طول هذه الازمه في ازل
الفريق او حتى تجريده من رتبته ولكن هذا
كان فيه دلاله في الايامات الاوضه ان
يتراجع هذا الشخص وان يتراجع الى فوضى
يعني يتفاوض المؤسسه العسكريه فبالتالي لا
ولديه كان طموح ربما طموح بالنسبه له طموح
مشروع فان يكون الرجل الاول السودان ولكن
في الواقع يعني المؤامره الاخيره التي قام
بها كشفت ان هنالك نوايا سيئه في تنفيذ
اجندات اخرى ليس ذات تصلها بالشعب
السوداني
بالسودانيين فبالتالي لا يمكن لا يمكن
للمؤسسه العسكريه ان تقبل اي حوار معه في
المستقبل
باعتبار ان هذا المكون هو عباره امليجيات
قبل طيب فقط ابقى معي سعود اليك نتابع هذه
الصور واياكم مشاهدينا هي صور اذا الان
لعضو مجلس السياده الفريق الاول ياسر
العطب وهو
يتفقد القوات التي نشرها الجيش السوداني
يوم امس بالخرطوم اذا هذا فيديو لعضو مجلس
السياده السوداني ياسر العطر وهو يتفقد
القوات
المسلحه قوات الجيش السوداني التي نشرها
الجيش السوداني في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وهي التي كما ذكرنا شهدت اشتباكات
عنيفه منذ الامس بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وكما ذكر الجيش
السوداني في تصريحات
للعربيه هذا اليوم بانه احكم السيطره على
عدد من المواقع الهامه في العاصمه
الخرطوم
اذا هذه صور كما ذكرنا واياكم لعضو مجلس
السياده السودانيه سبعته يتفقد القوات
التي نشرها الجيش بالخرطوم الجيش السوداني
كان قد ذكر للعربي بانه تجاوز مرحله
الصمود وبدا مرحله تنظيف بؤر انتشار الدعم
السريع اذا وهذه كما ذكرنا صور وفيديو
تداول اذا لعضو مجلس السياده السوداني
ياسر الفريق الاول ياسر العطاء وهو يتفقد
القوات التي نشرها الجيش في الخرطوم اذن
الجيش السوداني كما ذكرنا قال بانه تجاوز
مرحله الصمود وبدا مرحله التنظيف بؤر
انتشار الدعم
اذا الدعم السريع
وقال بان تراجع الدعم السريع من مناطق
انتشاره بالخرطوم شرط لاستمرار اي هدنه
وبانه تصدى للدعم السريع بمحيط القياده
العامه
وكذلك مطار الخرطوم وبان هناك دمار كبير
في عده مرافق
حكوميه اذا نعيد التذكير بان هذا الفيديو
هو لعضو مجلس السياده السوداني الفريق
الاول ياسر العطا وهو يتفقد القوات التي
نشرها الجيش السوداني بالعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم التي كما ذكرنا هي تشهد اشتباكات
عنيفه منذ سبعه ايام منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
بين الجيش السوداني وكذلك قوات الدعم
السريع اعود مره اخرى الى ضيف من القاهره
صلاح خليل سيد صلاح لا اعلم ان كنت تشاهد
هذا الفيديو امامك لكنه يعني فيديو لعضو
مجلس السياده طبعا هو يتفقد القوات التي
نشرها الجيش بالخرطوم ما هي دلاله نشر هذا
الفيديو في هذا
التوقيت
دلاله او رساله واضحه الى الذين يقاتلون
في قوات الدعم السليم بانه الجيش خصبسط
قوته وايضا الجيش استعاد الطرق والمرتكزات
التي كانت تقيمها قوات الدعم السريع
فبالتالي ما تبقى من حركات المقاتلين
الدعم السريع عليهم تسليم نفسهم لانه
الازمه انتهت الجيش حسب المعركه ليس هنالك
يجعل قوات الدعم السريس وكان الانسحاب ان
كانت لديها فرصه للانتها ولكن في اعتقادي
ارسال تواضعه بانه الازمه قد انتهت
وبالتالي الدعم السريع او الى قياداته
التي تختدي او مقاتلين الذين قاتلون في
صفوفهم الاستسلام للمؤسسه العسكريه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الى القاهره انضم الينا الباحث
في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه صلاح خليل شكرا جزيلا لك
ضحايا اخرون لهذه الحرب المدمره طلاب
المدارس والجامعات الذين اصبح انقاذوا
ارواحهم اولويه على انقاذ العام الدراسي
نتابع
مره اخرى يقاد السودان الى طريق التيه
ويطارد الموت الملاحقين منذ سنوات من اهله
بالخوف والجوع ولم تكتفي الحرب السودانيه
بما تحققه من خراب لتقرر المساهمه بخراب
التعليم عبر ضرباتها
من هذه الفتحه في احد اسوار هذه الجامعه
يخرج هؤلاء الطلبه الى حياه ابخست الحرب
منها وهي تنشر القتل في احياء السودان
وشوارعه وصولا الى تلك الجامعه عبر رصاصه
طائشه ازهقت روح واحد من الطلاب
مدارس وجامعات تاثرت بضربات الحرب ولقيت
ثلاثه تلاميذ مصرعهم نتيجه سقوط قذيفه
بالقرب من منزلهم بمنطقه شرق النيل مستقبل
عام دراسي ينتظر جلوس اكثر من 500 الف
طالب وطالبه لامتحانات الشهاده السودانيه
يثير القلق على مصيره لو استمرت المعارك
لايام
لكن هناك طلبه قرروا هجره الكتب والمدارس
بعد ان دمرت منازلهم واخطعت الحرب اهاليهم
على طرق درب النزوح حرب السودان كغيرها من
حروب عاشتها المنطقه تثبت بدورها ان
الاطفال والطلاب يبقون الخاسر الاكبر
ودافع الضريبه الاعلى عندما ينزلق قاده
الدول لحروب داخليه قد لا تبقي ولا تذر
[موسيقى]
الى جوله من الاخبار الدوليه المتفرقه حيث
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي خلال الاجتماع
حلفاء اوكرانيا في المانيا لتنسيق
المساعدات العسكريه ان واشنطن قدمت 36
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا بلغت
قيمتها اكثر من 35 مليار دولار
بدايه الاسبوع اعلنت الولايات المتحده عن
الحزمه 36 من المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا التي تبلغ قيمتها
325 مليون دولار اذا نحن قدمنا مساعده
عسكريه لاوكرانيا حتى الان بقيمه تصل الى
اكثر من 35 مليار دولار منذ بدء العدوان
الروسي الحزمه الاخيره تضمنت صواريخ هاي
مارس ومدافع 155 ملم و105 مليمترات
مستمرون بتقديم المساعدات لاوكرانيا على
المدى الطويل
قال امين وحلفي شمال الاطلسي ينسى ان جميع
اعضاء الحل في التفقه على ان تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو كما اكد
السولتنبر ان التركيز الرئيسي الان هو
ضمان انتصار اوكرانيا على روسيا مشيرا الى
انه يجب ان يكون
القدره لمنع وقوع اي هجمات اخرى بعد نهايه
الحرب الحاليه
اكد وزير الخارجيه الصينيه ان بلاده تلتزم
بالمبادئ العادله للدعوه الى الوساطه
والحوار للحد من التوترات في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
بما اننا نواجه ازمه طويله الامد في
اوكرانيا فان الصين لا تزيد النار اشتعالا
وتستغل الوضع ولكننا بدلا من ذلك نلتزم
بالمبادئ العادله للدعوه الى الوساطه
والحوار والحد من التوترات في الصراع
لتخفيف حده الوضع
وفي سياق اخر حذر وزير خارجيه الصيني من
ان انتقاد الصين بشان تايوان سيكون له
عواقب وخيمه وقال تشين ان هناك خطابات
تتحدث عن تغير الوضع الراهن من جانب واحد
عبر مضيق تايوان من خلال القوه او الاكراه
وتعطيل السلام والاستقرار عبر المضيق
مشيرا الى ان مثل هذه الادعاءات تتعارض مع
طبيعه العلاقات الدوليه ولها عواقب خطيره
هذه الساعه انتهت من تغطيتنا للمشهد
السوداني وتطوراته التغطيه مستمره ولكن
بعد قليل على راس الساعه مع زميل طالب
كنعاني لك طالب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات